now the ratios right the this is one of
the original
um order for those tools
and in the past it would always be a
blue number above or below the bar
whether it was a bullish number or
bearish number
we've changed that so that it's the
bullish
um ratios are going to be blue the
bearish ratios are going to be red
okay and it gets a little interesting on
how you're gonna you could actually draw
a zone out so the ratios that I use 30
for Price exhaustion
0.69 for Price defense
the zone is drawn to one now sort of one
of the differences okay is if it's a
bullish ratio
right you see this it's got the the
number underneath right the zero
but there's also a blue box just as if
there's a bearish ratio let's find one
here
again you know zero with the red box
around it
um
that's what the Zone drawn out to one so
if you don't want to do that
you just go in there you change that to
zero right then it would just print
um
then it will just print the
the
ratio the color blue for something
that's bullish or red for something
that's bearish so you can see it that is
sort of how the old version looked okay
except for
it was red for um bearish now again if
the number is just black that's just
your normal order flow
okay and it's going to plot right the
blue or the red if it's a bearish or
bullish ratio as well right right down
here
um one of the other things that you can
do is if someone you know when we're
putting this together I told my program
I said well
what about the bars you know where you
have something that's bullish or bearish
you know don't you sort of want to draw
the zone
and it's like you know where are we
going to draw out the Zone from on this
setting so
um until tested right again you know
I'm not sure if you could draw it out
with the Zone size of zero but I just
keep it at one
um what it's going to do is going to
draw it out from the ratio number it's
going to draw out the Zone from the
actual ratio number itself it's not
drawing so it's one tick below the low
of the bar or one tick above the high of
a bar
and you know you can see here right so
it just comes in again it's
not I don't want to say
right now that's not something I'm
focusing on on Trading
you know for pullbacks to a ratio
because I've never really looked at it
like that I've just looked at them for
because you know Rachel reads the order
flow in the bar
and what it's doing is telling you if
the bar has bullish or bearish order
flow right now so
um you know like for example even though
this Bar's got bearish order flow here
at 744
I'm not looking for the market
necessarily to come back to it all right
test that you know again within one tick
of that high and then you know move but
um because really what I want to be
alerted to with the ratios is what's the
order flow doing right now is it bullish
or bearish or just your normal order
flow right because I like to look at
them at
swing lows like here or
um if I got one on a swing High
um no but again it's I I then once we
started drawing out these ratios again
you know it's just one of those things
that I just found it
interesting
how often a markets sort of come back to
those
previous highs or lows of the bars that
have the bearish or bullish order flow
like right here
right
so you know right here as well
so that's you know how you could use you
know that's sort of one of the changes
in the um
overflows ratios
again you know I've done a lot of videos
on on the ratios what they mean and how
you could use them in your trading you
know some people have taken my years ago
when we first released the software
you know the ratios was one of those
that was the first piece in there you
know one of the four Legacy indicators
if you will because I used to calculate
these ratios by hand you know I want to
say by hand but on a calculator or in my
head
um and most of them I could do in my my
head but um
someone
you know there's no big secret you know
calculus that's involved there simple
um division but
you know someone copied it and put it
out as like this order flow algo
indicator or something that's like come
on and um but then again you know they
figured it out but then they don't know
how to apply it so you know a lot of
these tools
you know I'm the one that
I'll say invented them but I'm the first
one that started using them and
found them in the order flow based on
how I trade and then this is how you use
it so it's not like you know I got a
book on order filter I read a lot of
books now there's a lot of books on
trading order flow a lot of the same
things just copied out of my books out
of my courses
um you know and it's like I read some of
them and I'm just like these people
understand what they're they're doing
the way they're looking at it is is
incorrect
but um you know every Trader's got their
own opinion on the market now the PLC
slingshot is
it's a POC indicator again it's enabled
and it's fixed right for that bar
because you want to see the bars where
it's appearing like here this is a
bearish one
um
there's uh this was a bullish one
now you could
sort of one of the changes in the order
flows 6 version is
um
let me change that to fix is you could
again draw it out until tested okay
and
a slingshot point of control is it's a
it's a form you know anything dealing
with Point controls is in a way Sport
and resistance
so you know if I have if I know I have
this bullish PLC slingshot I know in
this bar I've got this support here so
I'm looking for it to hold over the next
several bars and it's going to give me a
nice trade
um to the upside as long as we're
staying above it you know I want to be
going in that direction you know if I'm
using prominent or so if I'm using the
slingshot point of control
um you know there was nothing else there
that was until tested but um you know
that's a bullish one
you know here's a bearish one here right
the market sort of came right back up
that level here Market sold off came
down to this bullish one it just sort of
went sideways you know this one went
sideways one two three bars in a row
um
scroll back so the bearish one
um let's go back to you know there's
another bearish one up here again you
know as long as I'm looking at it as
it's it's holding over the next couple
bars and I start seeing something
bearish in the order flow like here
right I got a bearish ratio I've got
um an exhaustion print in the next bar
another bearish ratio and
um you know a zero print actually
appearing in here as well you know it's
telling me yeah you know what I've got
this
overhead Supply and I'm getting bearish
information
you know you can see these bars got four
things in the order flow this one's got
four this one's got three
I said no okay yeah you know the the
order flow up here at the swing high is
kind of bearish
um now the next thing is uh since we're
on point of controls talk about the
Prominent Point of controls you know
primary point of controls are
um
so change this back to fixed
something that you know has been in a
few of the version earlier versions of
order flows and it helps you define you
know where there's supporter resistance
in the order flow based on the points of
control and there's three levels that
you can have there's level one level two
level three it deals with you know where
the point of control is appearing in the
bar you know relative to previous points
of controls because reported control is
the price level in the bar with the most
volume
and if you have certain point of
controls appearing at certain points in
a bar relative to previous bars it
can give you a clue as you know with
their support or resistance in the
market now by default they're all
enabled and they're all fixed but I know
some Traders
wrote me over the weekend saying you
know they love that now that you can
have it until tested
and you know it's just one of those
things that is going to give them that
extra visual he said you know it's all
about having the visuals like right here
at the swing High you got this bearish
Prominent Point of control right you see
this Market had this nice
um sell-off
you know you see the Market's sort of
coming back up to those levels doesn't
quite hit it
um you know here's another bearish
Prominent Point control this was a
bullish one here
um here's a bearish one
there's a bullish Prominent Point of
control this is the point of control on
the extreme
and
it was a very strong signal right they
even got a bullish ratio
um
an imbalance reversal
it came right down to that one traded
you know at that same level the market
popped up and again you know this is the
thing if you're looking at you know this
is your normal volumetric chart
you know what time was this this was
overnight
okay yeah well I mean the volumetric
chart at least it colors it red to tell
you it's important I don't know what
their colors mean but um
you know here you're seeing you know
there's a lot of things happening you
got a bullish ratio bullish order flow
because the bullish ratio you've got
obviously the point of control it's a
Prominent Point of control it's bullish
um you got imbalance reversal there as
well
but it's just a little bit easier to see
it here right because now you're getting
the plots in there
um
you know so again
um let's take a look you know
bearish behind upon a control here
bullish Department point of control here
now there's some markets you know where
it just seems you know treasuries things
like that in my opinion I've always
followed Prominent Point of controls uh
really well
and again it's not that you have to
trade it for a pullback there as long as
you got that Prominent Point of control
and it's holding you know you could
scalp it on the way up because you know
on the way back down you're getting some
bearish things in here right you got
that inverse imbalance Etc I mean order
flow is constantly changing
um but that was one of the the
new changes in this uh version is being
able to draw those out until tested
because you know it's something that
helps a lot of Traders
um find these areas of support or
resistance now stacked and bouncing
right we all know what stacked
imbalances are
it is um you know three or more buying
imbalances stacked neatly on top of each
other so it's enabled and it's fixed so
it's just going to appear in the bar
it's not going to draw it out
but again you could do it until tested
and you know maybe you I have it fixed
in the bar because I don't want to draw
too many zones you know at once and I
want you to just add the pieces of the
order flow that you want to look at
right like here's a nice stacked in
Balance being drawn out here's another
stacked and balance because oftentimes
the market is going to come back to
those levels it's going to test those
levels
you know because it's an area where you
had aggressive selling or aggressive
buying you know here right aggressive
buying you got sequencing you got a
stacked and balance you can see if the
Market's sort of going to come back
there you want to see those levels hold
now they're not going to necessarily
hold indefinitely because obviously
things are going to change in the order
flow
but when you see those areas
right you watch for them what happens
when the market comes back to those
levels right here's a nice stack behind
imbalance right Market went up
came back down
right to right to that area we had the
aggressive buying and then you see
buying again it goes back up where to
this previous High that's sort of to
follow up what I said about inverse or
you know some of these other
you know I think inverse balance was one
um
what was that one that I was just
talking about again my mind is um
Market sweeps you know here you got a
stacked imbalance at the high of this
bar but we're closing below it that's
not a good sign that
that it's going to be effective right if
you have a stacked imbalance you want to
be closing above it you want to be
trading above the Stacked buying and
balance you don't want to have a stack
aggressive trading and then the Market's
trading below it right that invalidates
that signal
right and again sort of to follow up on
my point is you know
you have this bar here it looks like
very bullish bar you got a lot of
going on right you got one two three
four five six seven plots seven bullish
plots
but the Market's backing off from the
area right you got the Stacked buying
imbalance right you've got the opponent
control on the extreme you've got a
imbalance reversal you've got a zero
print you got a bullish ratio
um you know and you got the engulfing
value area it's very bullish well
shouldn't the market go higher yeah it
should but it's not so what's that also
telling you well it's telling you
you know all is not right right you see
how the market eventually just sort of
sputtered out went sideways came off a
little bit went sideways um before
selling off right I mean that's part of
trading is understanding that oh you got
you know stuff that's very bullish but
the Market's not reacting that way
turns it into something bearish
okay so um let's just sort of chug
through
the rest of these so that was um stacked
imbalances where are we here
okay so again you know default is fixed
but again it's something you can change
too
um until tested if you like
now thin prints okay this is a new
indicator
there's two sections of this there's
thin prints just a normal thin print in
the bar
and there's
um excuse me
let me drink some water here
and there's multiple thin prints in a
bar
now so this is gold so I'll just keep it
at you know the default I think is set
to one but let's turn it to zero and
what that's going to look for are in the
bar
price
levels
where there's um no volume you know
there's no volume either on the bid or
the offer see here's this is a thin
print here
this is a thin print
thin print thin print
then print then print
then print then prints and you can
actually draw these out until tested I
know some people like to trade this
excuse me until tested
um let's just draw it on here
until tested
um because you're looking for you know
it's an area where you're expecting the
market to repair that area
okay so you're looking for the market to
come back to these areas
okay
now
you can see in here as well if there's I
talked about multiple thin prints in a
bar all right so let me just turn off
the until tested area
you see here multiple thin prints it's
going to draw it
dark green or dark red dark red for
bearish dark green for bullish okay so
might be a little bit hard to see but
you know when you start looking at your
charts it's going to stand out a bit
more
and again it has to be enabled for it to
appear like here this Bar's got multiple
thin prints one two three so it's a dark
red because bars that have multiple
imbalances is going to be red or blue
and you know bars that have multiple
like this one here multiple thin prints
here
you know
here right you got one two three four
five six right so it's just drawing it
out and again it's going to plot your
bar that has the thin prints in it
um you know that said dark plot right
there
and again you know it's something that
thin print when you see a thin print in
the bar again I have it set to zero but
you could use one two or three you know
if you're trading things like e-minis or
treasuries you know you could set it at
five or something
um it really depends on the volume that
goes through in your bar
in the market that you're Trading
uh so anyway that's a thin print so
again by default it is disabled even
though it's a new one
um again I didn't want to overwhelm it
but this is quite a powerful one now the
value areas right one of the big
differences is now we color them as
opposed to they're just Gray
in the past and by calling it sort of
brings your chart a little bit more to
life the difference of black and white
TV so if it's a bullish value area
meaning the bar is an up candle it's
going to color it green if it candle is
a red candle it's going to color it red
now the doji candles are still the gray
color but
um
you know
I've been playing around with it a
little bit you know just sort of
changing the colors to make it stand out
a little bit because you know as someone
was talking to me about uh you know bars
that you know double doji bars you know
through doji's in a row but yeah you can
color them the doji bar gold if you like
just to make it stand out a little bit
more you know there's a doji there as
opposed just you know the plain gray you
know a couple doji's up in here
um you know if you like looking for
doji's there's some Traders I know that
that's their whole trading plan is built
around looking at doji candles so you
know having that ability to color them a
certain color is it's going to help you
okay so again you don't have to change
the color
you know if you want everything gray as
it was before then you just keep the
color
um
black instead of green right because the
opacity the how strong it is is going to
be at 10.
engulfing value areas
it's going to be blue or red now
engulfing value area right we all know
what engulfing bars are right in
candlesticks well engulfing value area
is the value area that engulfs the
previous Bar's value area
um
and again you know it's quite useful
that especially when you see them coming
in at you know potential Market turning
points you know this was right off the
low this one was at the low this one
again didn't go anywhere this one you
got a little bit of a rally again that's
on Sunday night on the weekend on
let's go here to the day session you
know the bearish one here's a bullish
one
um you know here's a nice bearish one up
here at this swing High
now
again it will draw the uh you know plot
it okay on this one we don't
actually we do give you the evaluaries I
didn't talk about that but you the value
areas you do have
again the ability to draw it out
um until tested right
until tested until tested you know maybe
just you know you want to draw out the
just the engulfing value areas
until tested as opposed to both the
regular valuaries and engulfing I mean
you could do that okay see here I'd see
you know right up here at the swing High
you got that engulfing value area
um
so it's like
there's a bullish engulfing value area
right at the low of the day right when
you're looking for engulfing bars you
know you want them at areas where the
market could be turning because you know
it indicates a potential shift in
trading basically you know you're at
your low but now you've got a lot of
buying coming in some buying volatility
you know because volatility is what it's
price looking for areas it can transact
to so if price has got to cover a lot
more area
then
I'm often going to get a an engulfing
value area
okay so
um let's just scroll down in here uh
where am I here zero prints
again default is on it's fixed in the
bar and it's going to be dark green dark
red you'll pass these a little bit
darker
this is a zero print so if you have a
zero ratio in a bar it's going to give
you actually a zero print reading as
well but it's going to call it the top
two price levels on a bearish one on a
bullish ones the bottom two price levels
and you know these are areas where sort
of the market sort of when you have a
zero print it's really the market sort
of coming down uh testing an area and
then leaving it immediately so it's a
nice area for when
um you know you're looking for the
market to
uh Bounce from okay and it's also you
know nice to be used in a move right for
momentum
so you can draw it out until tested as
well
you know you see how the markets is sort
of coming back I don't think you really
need to do that
um I mean you can you know there's some
nice areas where the market comes back
to I just keep it as fixed but again
it's up to you you know to draw what you
want to have drawn out
again you know it's a momentum tool so
just seeing it in the bar
is something that uh
is useful to me I don't need to have it
drawn out not the latter content right
you have your normal bid ask
you could also have you know a Delta
candle sorry a Delta footprint you just
changed it from bit ask to Delta and
you know it'll just give you the Delta
at Price this is horizontal Delta
um you know at this price of you know 18
16 80 90. um
there was four more
traded on the bid side than the offer
side
now you also have you know you've got
your choices of um
let's go in here volume right the volume
for the price you know both the bid and
the ask combined as opposed to volume
trading on the bid
the volume traded on the ask and it's
just going to show it on one side of the
bar it's not going to put it in the
middle
just going to put it on the left hand
side and you also got your choice of
diagonal Delta right so that's the delta
in the two-way auction on your footprint
okay so
um you can see here how it looks very
similar to the regular horizontal Delta
again it's up to you which one you want
to use I I prefer bit ask and Delta
um but again you got those choices there
now you could actually add additional
point of controls like
the normal point of control is going to
appear in every bar as default it's on
but we set the pointer control two and
three to transparent so it doesn't show
you don't really need it now that we
have the value areas
um because you know obviously generally
you're gonna get all three point
controls in that value area anyway but
you have those you know you'd want to
make it a different color obviously than
black just sort of differentiate it
maybe you want it you know like red and
yellow but um you don't really need to
do that the short and big numbers
is you know on the bottom you know in
some markets that trade a lot of volume
you'll see like the volume for the day
here so today's kind of
nothing but um let's go back to
Friday
um again if you have the volume the
total volume for the day on your chart
uh or is it here total volume
it will just you know if it's over a
certain amount it just truncates it so
instead of saying you know 22
633 it would say you know like here
149.7 149 000
0.7 K okay so that's what that that's
what that is for
um the other thing is
there's a couple other little functions
in there uh or is it in here
uh uh uh tick aggregation if you're
trading something like Bitcoin or even
NASDAQ um you might want to use this you
know if you're trading Bitcoin you know
it trades in satoshi's and you could
literally buy you know a couple dollars
worth of bitcoin but it's going to
register as one trade
but you know you're not buying one
Bitcoin you're buying a fraction of it
and you know Bitcoin you know you look
at most charts and it shows you know
Bitcoin nineteen thousand four hundred
fifty three it's about seven one but
it's actually like nineteen thousand
four hundred seventy three spot seven
one six eight two three four seven so by
aggregating
the text you know it's going to make it
more
um you know the
19473 spot seven one and
NASDAQ right you know NASDAQ goes up you
know it's got a lot of volatility and it
covers a lot of price ranges some people
use the tick aggregation of four meaning
four ticks which is
one point you know that would be
um you know one
what do you want to call it one price on
the axis okay so to aggregate that up
and down tick you don't need to if
you're using Futures you don't need to
use that um but you have that function
like say people actually want to look at
4X you can the grid color you don't need
to worry about all that's going to do
transparent means it's you're not going
to see it but if it was you change it to
black or something then your chart will
just look like an Excel spreadsheet now
the summary content now there's a couple
changes in here right this is the
numbers on the bottom of your chart now
I don't keep them all but you could have
you know the ask and the bid volume I
just keep cumulative Delta Delta Delta
divided by volume max Delta Min Delta
and volume I don't use necessarily the
total volume
and you'll notice right there's some
changes here
and
total volume or should I Delta divided
by volume is one that we added this in
this version you can see it down in here
but let me just get to a sort of a
normal uh
scenario here
what do I got oh I got a uh
what footprint is this this is diagonal
Delta let me just change this back to a
regular bit ask Delta
uh
probably here
it's a little bit easier to see here
but
what we've done in this version okay is
we've highlighted certain things
in the numbers down here so you're
seeing right you're seeing some colors
some
fields are cyan or magenta and some are
white okay so on the Delta divided by
volume if it's over a certain threshold
right our default is set at 25 percent
I'm going to color it cyan color
meaning is strong
Delta right strong positive or negative
Delta so you can see it in here
95 you can adjust that right extreme
Delta and these are the colors extreme
buying stream selling
I'll show you 25 rather
um this other extreme Delta threshold of
95 is the other one which I'll talk
about in a second so
how I like to look at these is you know
sort of you know if we're at swing highs
or swing lows highs of days or lows of
days you know is there a very strong
aggressive buying coming in here we have
a nice swing low put in right here got
strong aggressive bind it's a cyan color
it's more to you know alert me hey Mike
you know what What's Happening Here
you've got something going on or after
this swing high is made right here what
do I see I see some strong aggressive
selling right I see the magenta I get
two bars here magenta magenta okay you
know I I don't want to be fighting the
order flow right I don't want to be
looking for reasons to getting long
because it's quite strong negative Delta
now the other thing is the final Deltas
right cyan or
magenta color right Magento is bullish
cyan is bearish so if I see cyan colors
what that's telling me on the final
Delta number the headline Delta it's
closing within a certain percentage of
the max or Min Delta so you can see here
these Deltas minus 36 minus 101 well
they're closing near its Min Delta
because they're cyan so this is minus 37
close at minus 36 minus 106 minus 101 so
I know that we are closing it at our
near our highest reading in terms of
aggressive selling in the Min Delta
right as we're just sort of coming up
around this turn so I see that
aggressive selling coming in now we're
been selling off then we start to turn
here I see the aggressive buying coming
in we got 106 Delta
it's magenta so it's closing near our
Max Delta which is our strongest Delta
was in the bar at 107. now you're going
to see also
the Max and Min Delta you can see white
colors white backgrounds
and
um
what that means is there's lack of
you know positive Delta or negative
Delta I don't want to say lack of
aggressive trading in the bar because
that's not true because you can see here
right this Delta's Got Just One Max
Delta but obviously there was people
buying the offer but at only one point
in this bar for you know a millisecond
where aggressive traders in control
and the next bar same thing to next bar
one so I know in this three bar stretch
you have three bars in a row where
aggressive Traders just didn't have any
control at all because normally you're
going to see trading back and forth
right you'll see some positive Delta
some negative Delta but when there's
really lack of
Max Delta or Min Delta and it's carried
over for several bars
that's important information right okay
you know God you know aggressive buyers
just never could have control here in
this market at this time so what's the
trade trade is to the short side
okay until you start seeing signs of
aggressive buying coming in
so that was you know these are visual
these you can't plot yet
um maybe in in the future version we'll
we'll do that but um
that's something to sort of help you
with your Delta analysis okay
it's just right here under the summary
content now unfinished business again
it's
by default it's off but if you want it
on you just click detect unfinished
business you can also draw the broken
levels if you like
um I'm not going to get into that today
the volume profile again you know if you
it's by default it's off but if you want
it on you just click display volume
profile which is this one choose if you
want it on the right otherwise it'll
show up on the left now this part in
here volume imbalance okay so there's
two parts to this one is the top part so
that volume and balance font is set to
14. that's related to what you're seeing
in the footprint the size and the color
red or blue
okay so if you want to adjust it you'd
adjust it from there
now
again in the global settings at the top
is what your imbalance percentages 400
appearance balance trigger in percent
400 is four to one
um the other part of the
thing in here is enable multiple
imbalances
and it's fixed meaning it just draws it
out
in the bar and what it's going to do is
going to put an outline
um in the bar you know again it
the colors you could change them if you
like uh I have olive drab and you know
this is green and chocolate
which is not brown it's more of this the
orange color but um
let's see you can see in here right this
chocolatey color here
um this olive drab color here
so you know other drab chocolatey that's
really like an orange or a green now you
can actually draw zones out from the
bars with multiple imbalances and
what's different about the multiple and
balanced zones
is uh
where is it here
when you draw it
until tested okay well first we'll draw
it fixed okay you'll notice I have it
set to zero if it is
um
set to one
it's going to draw the
it's going to highlight the higher the
low of the bar however it's not the low
of the of a up bar it's the high of the
up bar or the low of a red bar in the
the
um meaning for that is okay I've got
multiple silent balances in this bar so
I know that down here I want this Market
to keep going in that direction I got
I've got the momentum right so we need
to be trading below there's no point in
drawing it up at the top or drawing it
because you got multiple imbalances it
could be anywhere in a bar so like here
right this bar
got multiple imbalances they're spread
out there's one here two here one up
here one up here at the top okay so I
know there's multiple imbalances I need
to get past this level
for this to
be valid right if we can't get past this
level here it's not valid just as here
right here's your multiple selling
imbalances in this bar two three okay
this is to tell me hey you got multiple
sign imbalances we should be Trading
to the downside
not above
the low of this bar
okay and again you know multiple buying
imbalances yeah we want to be trading in
that direction multiple imbalances
remember is a momentum signal
so you want something to tell you
there's you know
where you should be trading above or
below now if you could actually draw
these out as well until tested
this is how it looks
let's give it a second here
right like this right here
I wouldn't use these as support or
resistance levels maybe you could use
them as as breakout levels but at what
point you know I mean I don't want to
like if you have
for example right if you have multiple
imbalances here I'm looking for this
Market to move now
I'm not waiting for it to come back you
know this is at 11 39 11 38 I'm not
looking for it to come back at you know
a half hour later and break through that
I'm really looking forward to break
through it now I'm looking for it to
move
in the next bar or the next bar
so but you can draw those zones out if
you want I don't think uh you really
need to but I don't know you know I'm
always surprised at the feedback I get
from users saying oh this is home using
it and
you know it just amazes me sometimes now
the stuff down here data series setup
visuals you don't need to test you know
touch those that's just telling you the
chart what it's looking at
um and where to plot it on the screen
now the plots right so this is the big
difference of the Oracle is Trader six
is the ability to plot all these
indicators and this is a list with all
the colors and you just open it up
and by default they're all the set the
same these triangles up or down up for
bullish down for bearish and again we
sort of kept all the colors you know
sort of shades of blue
for bullish blue and green for bullish
shades of red for bearish but again you
know you could change them I don't think
you really need to but I'm sure some of
you will
um but again if you're if you're using
some sort of analyzers these are the
plots that you're going to use in your
analyzer software
so you know you can see it's it's a
pretty
robust
um upgrade
hopefully you guys can
you know come back to me in in a few
weeks saying oh Mike you know this is
great I've gotten some great positive
feedback
um from Traders
over the over the weekend with the
software and again you know say you want
to
let's take a look here okay so this is
what is this gold okay so say you know I
I'm only interested in bars that have an
exhaustion print and
and I guess it'll start with exhaustion
print which sort of go through
um you know
has sequencing
has a ratio in it
um I don't need the Prominent Point of
control
um
doing this so you need that and a stat
and a thin print okay obviously every
bar is going to have a value area
um
okay but I don't need a zero print so
what it's looking for
and let's turn off the
multiple imbalances so basically what
I'm going to do is I'm telling the
system hey look for bars that have
exhaustion print I'm more interested in
bars that have exhaustion print
um some sequencing in order for those
ratio
and uh what was that one the thin print
right set at zero
and you know those are the trades that I
want to take you know where it's got
basically those four things appearing
all right so
I'm going to look for you know or maybe
just three out of the four right because
I realize you know not every bar may not
have a sequencing you know I'll look for
the bars that have the three right
because it's not that you can filter out
the bars that don't have them because
like this Bar's got the exhaustion print
so it's going to print the exhaustion
print exhaustion print as far as got the
exhaustion print exhaustion print and
um the thin print
you know but I would just be looking for
the bars that are showing me you know
maybe three out of the four you know
it'd be nice to get all four
but you know a thing like ratios
or sorry the thing like sequencing
isn't necessarily going to happen
um you know as often as we would like
but you know I'm sure there are going to
be some bars that have them
you know it's going to give you you know
all four plots
you know like this bar here it's got
everything he's got a little move up
um
so you know that's you know so how you
can advance your your trading you know
by focusing on the things in the order
flow that
are valuable to you right and and sort
of disabling the things
in the order flow that you know you
don't want to look at right say yeah I'm
like I just want just give me a software
that is going to show me
you know imbalance reversals until
tested fine okay you can just go and
enable that change it to until tested
disable
everything else that you don't want to
look at
you know you don't need thin prints you
don't need value areas
um any of that other stuff basically
okay so you know it's a much cleaner
chart obviously there's you know here's
one here's one here's a bullish one
here's a bearish one here's a bullish
one
um
you know bearish bullish bearish
which is drawing out those zones bullish
bullish so you know you have that
flexibility to refine what you're
looking at in the order flow
as opposed to having everything up there
that is confusing you because I'm a big
believer you know there's only you know
you only need to add the things to your
screen that's going to help you trade
it's going to help you find nice trades
as opposed to I got to put everything up
of there at once I mean you want to do
that you can just go through you know
need actually need the order for those
Trader software I mean ninjatrader right
it's got all these indicators in here
you could add throw them all up on there
right the little spaghetti system you're
not going to do that you want to add the
pieces of order flow that's going to
help your trading right help you become
a better Trader understand what's
happening in the markets